The Joe Rogan experience,
but like Japan is one of the most
unhappy countries in the world.
People at the suicide rate
is off the charts, but they
take themselves out. Yeah.
You know, in America it's like, let
me, who can I take with me? Yeah.
I don't know what that,
what that is. Well,
Japan emphasizes humility and uh,
they rewarded like if in the
emphasize being polite and orderly,
it's really interesting.
Um,
there was a dis piece I was watching
on Youtube of these people that live in
cyber cafes,
that they have cyber cafes that are open
24 hours a day in Japan and they have
like this little cubicles that you taken
there and they're just online on their
computer and they have all their things
there and that's where they live.
And they shower and then they
go back to the little cubicle.
But this woman was saying that it
made her feel like she wasn't alone,
but she wasn't with people either.
Like she likes that,
that like she wants to know
that there's people around her,
but she doesn't want anybody
in her life and also dark.
Yeah. Yeah. That's
super fucking dark, sad.
Just the loneliness like that.
That's a giant issue apparently
in Japan is how lonely people are,
which is incredibly ironic
when you consider that it's
probably one of the most
population dense places on earth
and Tokyo at least. Oh yeah.
I think it just working their asses off.
I mean they fucking loved at the jump
in front of the trends they live for it.
Like it really is like the of countries
that it's the least happy country in the
world.
Wow.
I think number like the happiest is like
someone's Scandinavian. Great. Yeah.
Sweden or some shit. Yeah. Yeah. Finland,
I think Finland like ranks very highly
on that. Yeah. Why is it got it.
The thing I was watching said it
was like a sense of community.
I think that checks them live together
and like they eat their meals together as
like a neighborhood almost and they just
like everyone contributes and they're
just happy and content.
That makes sense.
The numbers are smaller too
and think that that helps also.
It's gorgeous up there. That helps too.
It's a lot of factors there, right? Yeah.
Like, what's a big city
in Finland? Helsinki.
How many people's at 50 how many
people live in Helsinki Fizzy?
50 55 at 50 I pay you right?
Feel like I would,
I bet Helsinki as 1.2 million people.
How many people Helsinki have?
That's a wild guess. I don't know
why I had to put the 0.2 in there.
I'm hedging my bet. Like if I was
on the prices right thing instead.
It's the biggest,
but the thing I pull up doesn't say the
second largest says 279,000 so say what
he'll think he does. Well, it
doesn't, you can't. Doesn't.
If you Google population of Helsinki,
the very first thing I had,
which was the biggest cities in Finland,
I figured it would have had,
it just blew up. Five 58
558,000 yeah, that ain't shit.
Wow. That's it. That's why they're happy.
It's basically like four boulders. Yeah.
For Boulder. Colorado's and it's a
whole country. Yeah. You go to boulder,
some of the nicest people ever.
Why 100,000 of them? That's it.
Hard to build there. Beautiful,
bold, beautiful, beautiful,
gorgeous, grey people.
Little on the social side,
but I get it a little
too many Birkenstocks and
tables and girls could use a
little bit more makeup, pull makeup
on gals. It's not all it up a little.
It's not pronounced Tiva.
Tivos maybe it is divas.
I Dunno if I've even heard the word
weird leather sandals and shit,
but it's a cool place,
man. But I think, you know,
that's what you get if
you live around nature,
you get a bunch of fit people that like
hiking and shared a lot of north face
jackets. You know, they've got great
weather. Yeah, yeah, they'd really do.
They have blue blizzards
and snow storms and shit,
but they also have like you'll,
it'll be 30 degrees in Denver or boulder,
and then the next day it'll be 60
yeah. It doesn't make any sense. Okay.